c'est pourquoi je les fais passer un
entretien il va donner parfait devrait
arrêter là lui donner le boulet ses
actions et réactions si la cour juin moi
je suis en face tracker j'ai beau ça que
ça bouge chez nous on a besoin de gens
qui sont prêts à se battre pour
l'entreprise et on sait la récompense
est rare match est pas bon smart
metering une rencontre win win
bush qu'il est à combien mais qu'est ce
qu'ils racontent allait passer à autre
chose
alors pour le poste on est à la croisée
des chemins entre une mission
d'analystes de chargés de clientèle et
de collaborateurs aux stratégies avec
une dimension conseil audit reporting
enfin si ça veut dire quelque chose on
est plutôt orientée sur du doubs dignité
goody et le bio je comprends pas ce que
tu dis oui c'est quoi votre dose
staffing vous devez pas en tête là mais
de quoi je vais t'en part mais je suis
pas sûr qu'il faille rentrer dans des
détails trop spécifique pour l'instant
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
connaître votre approche sur ce genre de
mission alors mon absence ça m'intéresse
je les rends théorique
non ça m'intéresse moins la demande il
avait sérieusement qu'est ce que chirac
acheter quoi le sens de tous un monde
ressources humaines sa place que ça veut
dire
moi je vois vous êtes une entreprise
jeune fille zellik il chante bien
l'humain il ya là deux humains il a que
moi j'interviens
on est là dans la phase de l'eau en
france plein de choses qu'on comprend
qu'à moitié au moins construit régime et
ip long métrage où je serai là sur un
lit d'hôpital en train de crever je
regarde en arrière je me rendrai compte
que j'ai passé ma vie à parler de choses
qui veulent rien il faut penser à
hauteur de 26 ans hélas ces gogos
no - ça bouge voilà je réunis vie c'est
mon beau pourquoi on se sent pas qu'il
est enfin se passe quoi la fin effet
levier effet levier et on crampton
crampton grande honte chaque look api
melki et je suis furax fusa plus ac est
alors prends ça faux comptes chez les
hôtes à mon enfant un sérieusement
peu importe il est où qu'est-ce qui
dirait si vous vous lamentations il
comprendrait pas tu te dirait de fuir 30
ans de bâton alors forêt chez les arbres
la mousse l'humus je vais traiter les
arbres la nature mais oui tu dois faire
ma photo santé ce bordel impasse yasmine
pas 360 700 déployés mais elle prend des
courants ascendants section revient
nuages bas je monte dessus
je redescends je me pose qu'est-ce qu'il
ya les pieds dans la terre la terre
voilà je suis la terre c'est ça la vie
je dispose business model qu'est ce que
ça veut dire non ça veut plus rien dire
aujourd'hui c'est un de vous par ses
bons placenta ça je suis un organisme
vivant vivant vivant et c'est ça la
terre retourne à la terre le vent la mer
l'eau une fleur de toutes façons de la
mer oui de l'eau la vie de l'eau vite de
l'eau la vie voilà l'eau l'eau c'est la
vie je suis l'eau au haut à jouir d'eau
vivre il faut vivre il faut s'échapper
moi je suis pris au piège c'est trop
tard mais toi toi tu peux encore être
sauvé l'entreprise c'est un organe
autonome ferme là maintenant je vais te
libérer
c'est ça le sens c'est ça ma mission
balle et on veut le toit mon petit
oiseau chez le poste mais non
[Musique]
sur toi